[Music]
stanford university
today's session is on investing in the
next generation of robotics cyber
security and enterprise i.t the session
is named because those are the three
focus areas that tj focuses on so
tj was previously a managing partner out
of utah currently general partner at
next 47 and he focuses on those three
areas that i highlighted when he was at
ink utel it was quite interesting
because that's the non-profit strategic
venture arm that operates on behalf of
the u.s intelligence committee and he
was leading a number of investments in
cyber security and data center
technologies a number of companies that
many of us have heard today since
they're listed on the public stock
market he invested on pre-ipo early on
and those include fire eye cloudera pure
storage and of course a number of other
investments we love that tj is a
stanford grad he did his mba at stanford
and also did an undergrad at university
of virginia so tj thanks for joining us
today i'll go over to some of the areas
we talked about robotics cyber security
and enterprise i.t and also sprinkle in
your investment experiences on that
front does that sound good
it sounds great thank you for the
invitation to join and i'm excited to
talk with everybody it's more fun for me
if there are people jumping in with
follow-up questions or counter opinions
even so please please do that along the
way
sounds great especially since i think
opinions around what to invest in always
varies from person to person starting
with robotics would love to hear more in
terms of how do you think about
investing in robotics companies and also
how do you define
and narrow that definition of what you
consider robotic autonomous driving has
seemed to be
the key target for a lot of investments
that vcs have made in robotics but do
you consider that for instance as part
of the definition for robotics and
actually sergey from the class had an
interesting question in which he asked
why is robotics
a disliked area for vcs so would love
your thoughts um on that as well
sure that's a great question and maybe
we can get off that one i think people
are afraid of areas where they've lost
money in the past and a lot of a lot of
investors in the past have been excited
about anything that's fun to talk about
at cocktail parties i'm going to express
a little bit of self-loathing for the
investment persona the real stars of all
this are always the entrepreneurs and
the technologists that are making these
new products people get excited about
cars things that fly or robots because
and from personal experience i know this
it's it's more fun to talk to people
about those investments and it's
certainly just more inherently
interesting than to talk about database
technology even though there's more
money spent on database technology and
it's easier to create new companies
around it but a lot of people have lost
money a few people few investors have
made money in robotics with some
significant counter examples
and today especially most investors are
excited about software
and sas based businesses that have great
recurring revenue streams and great
margins
robotics companies because they're this
mixture of software and hardware we look
for ones that have all the ip and mostly
ip and software still have a typically
lower margin profile than a pure
software company
and there's some hard challenges that
they're working to address ernestine you
asked how do we define it what areas
that we look at in our autonomous
vehicles part of it certainly i'd put
autonomous vehicles as example of
robotics
and how do we automate
discrete systems that move so that that
goes from anything from the kind of
robot we've all imagined would be around
the house including ones we see like
roombas but into autonomous vehicles but
in less exquisite contexts into
purpose-built systems that operate
without humans driving them we could
have some in the portfolio that we can
talk about drones count robots that just
do one thing and do it very slowly not
around humans are some of my favorite
targets these days you think about one
of ours which is the avid bots a floor
cleaning robot
you take some of the same self-driving
technology that was that was developed
for autonomous vehicles and you apply it
to a system that instead of going 70
around a lot of other cars it's going 2
miles an hour
with no no people around weighs a lot
less it's got a lower lower bill of
materials
it's just a more tractable problem and
one that can go after a point economic
roi and that is really the final punch
line when we're looking at robotics
opportunities it's not just is the
technology great but does this address
uh identifiable pain point that
somebody's willing to pay for
and that's often
what's missed with what makes frontier
investing in frontier tech investing
dangerous is because
the technology can be so awesome and so
alluring that you forget or
neglect to square that with who's going
to pay for it i'd love to dive more into
specific applications and verticals of
robotics that do you produce that roi
that people are willing to pay for and
for me i i would consider it as there's
certain jobs that people and employers
naturally have trouble staffing even
during times of high employment and the
robotics can come in and solve those
problems and we love your thoughts in
terms of just thinking of a couple
verticals being like warehouse
automation fulfillment there is
obviously amazon's acquisition of kiva
that pushed that construction maybe
retail food agriculture the medical
field has seen a number of different
solutions that have been solved with
robotics what are some of these
verticals that are exciting for
investors to put money into and are
there ones that just don't really seem
viable like consumer electronics for
instance or what are your thoughts on
verticals that have high potential for
startups
yeah i like the framework of first is
there something that a robot can deliver
that is not possible today so improved
capabilities and i think a lot of
surgical or healthcare-focused robotic
systems can fall into that category not
an area i know well or i've invested in
but there's been a good number of
success in that sector drone
applications of drones end up in that
bucket as well because you can enable uh
rate of inspection or leverage on human
workforces in in ways and collection of
new data that you couldn't get with
manual systems because you can get to
places and get there faster and you can
respond better than you could in the
past
the second thing i think of
if it's not about improving capabilities
but it's about cost replacement and
human augmentation or human staff
augmentation is what's the labor date
labor rate you are uh replacing
and
are there some sort of extreme
constraints either seasonally or
consistently that uh make it hard to
staff against your labor needs and so
interesting you mentioned warehouse
robotics those the warehouse
environments go through these crazy
seasonal swings where
even amazon takes everybody in the
company and sends them to the dc's to
help with fulfillment at the holiday
season robotics is clearly a great win
for spiky needs like that where you flat
out cannot hire enough people at certain
times of the year harder cases to make
and ones that i like to avoid are
where you don't have any of those
dynamics i don't know if anybody was
around when at the stanford mall there
was the melt was a
grilled cheese
a fast casual restaurant with
robotic grilled cheese machines
which is cool and you want to go get a
grilled cheese from the melt when it
exists and i think it raised a bunch of
money from sequoia but the labor rate
that you're replacing just isn't
compelling so how do you do can you
really afford to pay for really
expensive grilled cheese robots when
your alternative is a pretty low cost
labor
so we think about i think about
restaurants
in retail but especially restaurants in
that category ag because of the scale
and again lower labor rate at least
labor is a percent of the overall cost
structure often ends up in that category
too so the zod had a question um do you
want to jump in with your question cool
yeah i was just wondering like do you
think there will be like a technology
shift in the next few years in robotics
or is it like more like a continuous
trend that things are getting better i'm
mainly wondering because i feel like
deep reinforcement learning stuff are
relatively new in research in the past
few years so i'm wondering like will
there be like a gpt moment or something
like that or yeah or is it continuous
i think it is fairly continuous for most
robotic systems the all robotic systems
benefit from some of the same
advancements so slam so localization and
and path planning object recognition
these are giant leaps forward that we've
seen in the last 10 years from your
computer vision standpoint so their
robotic systems are benefiting from that
they also benefit from sensor
improvements and minor radar but i don't
see on the horizon a big leap forward
from there i think it's a lot of
distilling to practice
new tech that is is already accessible
what do you think is that
yeah it makes sense yeah i i just wonder
because i feel manipulation stuff are
still not as good as like motion and
like locomotion and stuff yeah but i'm
generally curious so at this area and
yeah one of the one of the things that
we've invested in the last year was a
system that's designed to help
uh
human operators of robotic systems in
industrial environments so these are
robotic arms that do operations at
cellular manufacturing primarily
reconfigure or retrain those systems
without having to call in an outside
expert
and so this is how do you become more
flexible as a manufacturing facility and
how do you avoid the cost and time of
those outside contractors
and that is some of the same aim so
flexibility and ability to retrain but
through a very
simple
approach which is to have a stylist that
teaches the robot what to do next and
how to do it in smart software
and that ends up being more accessible
in the near term than relying on the
cutting edge reinforcement learning yeah
it makes sense in that one case yeah
thanks for the question tj in terms of
challenges with robotics either from a
when you're thinking about it from an
investment standpoint either a
technology challenge or market or roi
sort of challenge are there certain
inverting holes that you would avoid
applications of robotics in
i
like to avoid things i don't know
anything about so i avoid healthcare and
surgical applications even though they
could be great investments i acknowledge
that
i also avoid ones that that
typically have a hard time adopting new
tech and so these are legacy markets
where the buying behavior is very
fragmented
a great example is construction
so
we've got a great investment in a
company that retrofits
excavators
to dig autonomously and that is civil
engineering and it's at a pretty big
scale it's great for trenching it's
great for foundation work but when you
get to the many different teams that are
building a building there are a bunch of
startups that are focused on helping
that process be more efficient there is
huge and identified need
for that but
no buying behavior that stands today
that really supports big significant
purchases and so we like to avoid that
kind of fragmentation in markets and
then i'd go back to ag and say it's not
for instance vertical farming was
extremely hot about five years ago a lot
of money went into vertical farming
and the
hardest part about that was both the
buying behavior but also the analog
risks associated with and the biological
risks associated with trying to automate
and have indoor farming because you can
have some contamination a little bit of
algal growth and then at all you've lost
the entire crop and that's not something
you can solve with software
typically
the civil engineer in our class has a
follow-up question or comment to your
point
yeah just as a follow-up you mentioned
the there's a ton of startups in the
construction industry focused on trying
to improve the efficiency of
construction but just not a lot of
buying going on in that market i was
just curious if you had any idea why or
if there are any other markets that are
notoriously stubborn and if there's a
particular reason or if it's just
construction in general that's the
outlier
it's a great question i i think any so
we can point uh we can point to many
industries where they're just massive
and they could definitely benefit from
improved tech but they're not used to
doing it so it's just gonna take a long
time for for that uptake so
construction's an example retail's an
example and we'll come across more ag i
think ag's got a good history of big
robotic systems like combines and gps
enabled rtk enabled tractors but at this
time ag falls in that same category i'd
say construction
we did we got really excited about some
entrepreneurs because they were they
were great teams and they had some good
products it was almost all software
based it was just some easy to use
optical capture systems
and they're going to help contractors
and teams of contractors manage progress
against plan
create as builds you do all the things
that
you really want to do better and faster
as a big construction team which is
really a series of small teams
the challenge that we saw after talking
to big general contractors is that
each project is managed as a separate p
l a separate business and so there's
very limited centralized buying
of products
and therefore
on each project there are
about 60 different applications that are
purchased and built against the profit
of that project
and the amount of money that can go to
any one of those 60 apps
is constrained so i think what we're
looking for and someday this will change
is the team that cracks the code
on or just the general market shift
where there's centralized buying
every single project that a gc
undertakes
benefits from these these centralized
buys there have been great successes
playing grid is one
right so just planning and bim but for
that intersection of software and
robotics we're still watching
do you see anything different
no i just
i i agree that it's just a weird problem
and i like your perspective on that it's
just fragmented into specific projects
where the bottom line is everything
and taking a risk and being the first
person on such a large expensive project
is dangerous because
there's just there's risk there and so i
think you've nailed that and i like that
perspective thank
you cool thanks
so we have a question from andrew as
well related to autonomous vehicles
and efforts on retrofitting vehicles
with autopilot i assume andrew feel free
to chime in but a lot of startups have
tried to tackle that problem first just
because going into full autonomy is very
challenging yes i feel like a slightly
broken record because this is just
something that i'm personally
intimately aware of because i've done it
to my car yeah yeah so it's a lot of fun
and so i was just curious to hear what
you had to say about it it's a great
question and if i hadn't
and so i know of a team that is pursuing
this there's a company called ghost
i think it's called ghost anyway it's a
retrofit system for existing cars to
become
uh level three level four autonomous
and the founder is the smartest engineer
i've ever met there's something
interesting there and i've learned a
long time ago not to discount this one
founder or the primary backer
who's mike spicer at sutter hill who is
probably the best investor in the world
today
all that said like the core questions
are people ready to
do this are there is there an
installation network that can be built
to do this retrofit
and
what are the
what are the
inherent limitations to performance and
you have this asymptote of performance
that is lower because it's a retrofit as
opposed to a unified system and most of
the cases where we've looked at
autonomous
robotics you benefit greatly from having
the whole system really tightly
integrated because you know exactly
where
the sensors are
you can optimize processing and power
draw for the onboard slam and path
planning you need to do so it becomes a
bigger challenge if you have to
calibrate for each system that you're
applying onto
i guess that one interesting thought
experiment is
how accessible the build materials
of the system you did would be for the
mass market and whether you could do it
on the cheap because i've seen actually
a lot of the the early self-driving car
startups
everybody would use ford fusions because
they were drive by wire more than other
cars
and some would just use in a really
impressive way just webcams so there was
one that was just webcams
and i remember going on a drive around
sunnyvale
and
it did a great job
and it just had you sit in the back seat
and you'd see it stop at stop signs and
make turns and avoid traffic
and then your back would start sweating
because there's so many cpus
or so many servers crammed in the trunk
you know it's just hoovering up all the
onboard energy and not
the type of thing that works technically
but doesn't scale so well to the mass
market
yeah the the system i have is like
much further in its infancy compared to
that it's quite simple it's just some
heavily modified android phone just when
like a 3d printed casing that's like
just glued to the windshield and then
the car like already has some
pre-existing interfaces to like turn the
steering wheel like with the lane keep
assist features that you'll find
standard on like most new toyotas that
gives you some way to turn but it's not
enough torque to like really turn the
car like a lot so it won't probably
won't be taking turns stock but it's
interesting it's it it certainly can't
fully drive itself yet super cruise
technology like a package that you'd see
on a lot of oem cars it's fairly similar
yeah probably a little better probably
comparable to what tesla has right now
that's awesome that's impressive
and it's not very expensive to have an
android phone in the
onboard chat yeah no no definitely not
it's uh definitely manageable
cool
josie has a question around remote
assistance system as well
jesse do you want to jump in with your
question yeah i can do that my question
was just how you invest in remote
assistance systems and whether that kind
of falls under robotics and how those
companies are seen or evaluated given
that like the ultimate goal of most of
the robotic systems or supporting is to
minimize any of that human like touch
and can you help me with an example of a
remote assistance system i just don't
know
yeah yeah so i actually worked at amazon
for a couple of years before coming to
stanford it was a robotics program
called amazon scouts like a robot that
drives on the sidewalk to deliver
packages and one of the ways that we
actually accelerated our operations when
like the autonomy was not quite working
or
had some gaps basically was that you
have remote human
monitors that can take over when the
robot is confused i think there are
companies that have done this in
autonomous like self-driving cars as
well or trucks but it's more
about like
the final steps in your self-driving
process like a human
uh in the loop to help you navigate the
parking lot or something like that but i
imagine there's other i think in
healthcare as well there's it's more of
a human working with the robot but i
imagine there's always this force that's
trying to get the robot to do more and
more of the work
yeah it's interesting because there were
a couple startups that were focused on
we're not going to make an autonomous
truck we're just going to make a truck
that can be teleoperated really well
and the big challenge that we saw was
that if you're planning to do
teleoperation consistently for an
autonomous vehicle then you need
something like 250 millisecond latency
which is right at the edge of really
strong cell coverage
and you don't want to count on that if
you're trying to drive all over the
country so there was a connectivity
challenge there the other form we see is
exception handling which is i think what
you described at amazon which is a slam
dunk great way to get
around things that will pop up
in any deployment that are hard to
address or hard to predict
and we've got that with some of the
products that we've invested in where
it's a team of humans that says okay
this there are 300 robots out there
we're a team of 10
and we'll get alerts every once in a
while that one is stuck because somebody
uh blocked it in a weird way and it
needs to understand the path around it
because it's never dealt with this
before
the only challenge there
is
that
whatever you end up constructing in
terms of that team it's inherent
overhead and so it just hits your gross
margin
but it can be a great either medium or
long term if you can scale it
effectively approach to handling these
exceptions tj i do want to touch upon
one other question with regards to
robotics before we move on to cyber
security and enterprise i.t just limited
on time which is this past year has
definitely been interesting with the
rise of stack financing we've seen a lot
of liquidity available for investors and
robotics companies with zaps and the
whole idea of for the class special
purpose acquisition companies and plague
check companies where it's been a way
for a lot of companies to
avoid the traditional ipo process but
still go public because this blank check
company acquires the private company
personally i think it's been an
interesting opportunity for some of
these hardware intensive companies to
get faster access to large amounts of
capital that can fund product
development over several years but tj
would love your thoughts in terms of
staff over the past year especially and
how this affects someone who might be
looking to start a robotics company
yeah it's a question of the day and it's
i love everybody's thoughts if i guess
we have a lot of time together we go
running around on this one it's an
amazing trend
this is the amount of money that's been
vectored via specs to startups that are
pre-revenue or just into the revenue
growth
has been profound and it's been a really
compelling low cost of capital for a lot
of these companies
the
question in my mind is can you count on
it being there in another year or two or
three
and i'm not convinced you can and and
it's i was just talking with a team that
we work with and
they just raised 100 million dollars and
then
are thinking maybe down the road the
next round will be a spec
because we get access to even more money
and it'll be even lower dilution and i
think where we came out was we all
agreed that specs
nine to 12 months from now will either
be
significantly more legitimate because
there'll have been the success cases
that have started to ramp revenue and
have demonstrated that they were not
incredibly risky and probably riskier
than any of the investors really
understood
or it'll be a lot less less legitimate
and a lot of the specs will get beaten
up in the markets and the sec will come
down hard on them
we've seen that in the last few weeks
where the sec has removed some of the
safe harbors and removed some of the
potential for these companies to make
forward-looking claims that are really
aggressive and dna insurance is almost
impossible to get if you're on the board
of a spag
so i think it's strained right now i'm
hopeful that there are success cases it
has been a profound trend an amazing
thing that i couldn't have predicted
everyone was quite scared with once
covet hit and everything started
shutting down that we all had to extend
cash reserves for portfolio companies
and then all of a sudden all these ipos
are happening and
the stock market bounces back up with
without even without pre-vaccine days so
just the the insane amount of capital
availability yeah it means that you can
get access
if you have the profile that investors
either public or venture investors get
excited about you've got endless access
to capital and it's on the order of
hundreds of millions of dollars whenever
you want to
and it's something i've i've never seen
before it's amazing for the sake of time
would love to dive into cyber security
obviously a space that you spent a lot
of time in both at next 47 as well as
previously i think you tell what is your
general investment thesis on investing
in cyber security companies
yeah it's interesting because it's it's
one of these things that's it's there's
always opportunity it is always a
derivative of new compute environments
and in new ways in which people use
systems
and anytime you make a shift in how you
use compute or systems then there are
new vulnerabilities that pop up and then
those vulnerabilities lead to new
products
and those new products can give
companies initial escape velocity the
hard part is what i believe the
long-standing truism that to be a big
company in cyber you have to be a
multi-product company
and so that initial product has to be
the starting point you have to be able
to draw a line from that initial product
to several products the other thing that
we really like to see is
going after existing buckets of budget
dollars because trying to convince
the world that they need a new type of
cyber security and i think an example i
think of is 10 or 12 deception networks
startups that were around i was very
excited about and have run their course
in the last five years versus the next
great firewall company or endpoint
company
where there's already tens of billions
of dollars to spend in that sector
ready to go from old legacy provider to
to a new startup
and it's just a much easier sales motion
maybe we can dive into a specific
example an investment that you made
while at a utah firearm obviously a
well-known cybersecurity company
nowadays but what drove you to invest in
that company and as you answer that
would love for you to also address
zach's question which is
given that think utah is affiliated with
the government the incentives are
different for
investing in
fireeye versus if you are a traditional
venture fund
investing on behalf of lps purely
motivated by returns for example
yeah i would love to and i've lived both
sides of it so i'd love to comment on
that a little bit i think fireeye really
is is a
an extra sweet spot in cyber investing
and that is
uh use of a new technology to secure
systems as opposed to a new system to
secure a new technology the distinction
i'll make is when hypervisors emerge
there were a lot of startups that said
hey we're going to secure the hypervisor
fireeye said we're not going to secure
the hypervisor we're going to use
hypervisors to secure systems and so
they in essence they used lightweight
virtual machines that became this
concept of sandboxes that allowed you to
have a dual trigger approach to
determining whether
traffic coming into your network was
malicious and that greatly reduced false
positives and allowed them to sell a ton
of their systems and deliver a lot of
value to customers so i like that if you
can identify now it's containers or
serverless functions lambda functions if
you can if if you a talented team or
investor can identify companies that use
those new technologies to improve
security it's better i think with better
upside than
to find ways to secure those new
technologies the difference between
inkytel and
other investors inkital is designed to
provide access
really a bridge between hard to reach
customers in the intelligence community
and new technologies
and so it needs to configure itself for
access
not for
having big stakes in the companies it
invests in and not for management
not for optimizing financial return so
ink utel is partially dilutive capital
it delivers revenue and it delivers
customer insight
and represents and then in the good
cases a call option into growing
presence in the federal market with
these hard to reach customers down the
road so a great point of leverage for
the companies it works with it trades
that for again
amount of a cap table that it looks to
acquire because it does not want to
compete with all the other traditional
investors out there
because it needs that access
and it trades it for speed because it
wants to characterize end user interest
and exactly what they'd want to see out
of a product before making investment in
most cases
and i compare that to where i am now and
we're growing next 47 as a traditional
fund one lp but operating at speed so we
will sometimes have a first meeting with
the company and if it's in a sector we
know then we're running a term sheet in
three days and that could be a term
sheet where we're trying to invest 40 50
million dollars that's nothing special
that's what every investor does these
days and it is a just a different cycle
to a different end and question from
jason is how do companies and
entrepreneurs generally perceive
a fund like inkytel being
government-backed versus something
that's more of a traditional venture
fund and
i think one thing that's interesting is
um obviously in my mind intel's
definitely built this great reputation
over the last few years but curious tj
from your experience pre-fire idea
pre-some of these really notable
investments that inkytel made what was
it like convincing entrepreneurs to take
money from intel compared to another
venture fund
you know it was it took time for guitar
to be viewed as a valid partner and when
something
is done over and over again with enough
co-investors in a tighten up geography
so especially around the bay area then
people get to know that
it's nothing it's something to be
embraced because the there is value
conveyed and that's in in customer
insight and then and in revenue
and so we had to go through a lot of
those cycles to build the reputation
again we're not competing with investors
and that helped out or inkytail i still
say we sometimes do those five years ago
that helped a lot that we were all
pulling the same direction both
companies investors and in quito
so recently been all over the news two
state sponsored hacks on the u.s one was
the russian cyber espionage campaign
known as solarwinds that compromised
nine federal agencies and about 100
private companies and the other was the
chinese hack of microsoft exchange
servers would love your thoughts in
terms of can you share what exactly
happened during these attacks
how do we think about preventing these
attacks from happening and
more broadly what are some cyber
security trends
that we should think about that
investors vcs should
put money into given these sorts of
attacks that are happening with greater
frequency
yeah it's interesting that i won't go
super deep on either of them because i'm
not i'm not super deeply either of them
but the there are vast differences
between the two so the chinese
backed attack against exchange servers
something like 30 000 different servers
were compromised and that allowed for
likely capabilities backdoors installed
that could very least monitor
communications within those servers that
were compromised and potentially migrate
into other systems connected systems so
very significant the thing you gotta
wonder about there maybe you have an
opinion ernestine or anybody on this
call is why would you do that
because 30 000 servers is not subtle
right and it's not targeted
and it's going to be it's going to be
discovered
pretty quickly and it's going to be a
giant headache to clean up but it's not
something that's clandestine and to me
that's maybe trying to make a statement
or maybe
a mistake something was released and or
maybe it's a you know semi party
that was not managed effectively
on the solarwinds attack this was a
pretty specific spectrum attack where
software that was going to be used by
other systems was compromised and then
that allowed for future compromise of
the companies that had deployed it
seemed pretty brilliant pretty very
sophisticated and it took some of the
best security researchers in the world
to figure that one out and it was
targeted enough or at least could be
used in targeted way that i think was
very significant the the two attacks to
me it's like
one's a great ad for office 365. maybe
nobody wants an on-premise exchange
server anymore and for
cloud-based security the other one
i don't know i don't know how companies
end up changing what they do i think it
leads to probably shift left security
and products that help developers make
sure that what they're doing is reviewed
and highly secure so there's probably
some momentum there
what's funny to me is
big seemingly nation space
state-sponsored attacks like this
in my experience don't move the market
and buying behavior of corporations that
much
and i think that at least in the u.s
they rightfully assume that the defense
against these nation-state attacks is
really the domain of the government
and of organizations that have special
authorities to to do that to conduct
that defense
where things really people really start
paying attention is when
techniques and tactics refined by
these early attacks transition into
money making mode
so we saw that with botnet cycle on the
2010 time frame we're seeing that with
all the ransomware
work right now
and when
criminals are using uh new techniques to
make money or to
disrupt systems
then new products people are spending
money on new products in a huge way
so i think we're going to see continued
ramp and cyber spend and people are
always going to be asking how any new
product is going to help them defeat
uh ransomware these days or anything
else
i was just thinking it's quite
interesting that even just the attack
that happened about a day ago that i
neglected that she mentioned was also
around hackers shutting down pipelines
and when you are a fun trying to focus
on cyber security as an investment
thesis it does seem that sometimes these
attacks don't actually allow you to get
more money from lps it's not necessarily
a correlation as you mentioned between
increasing attacks
directly tied to more investment dollars
being put into the sector yeah i think
the other funny footnote to the pipeline
attack was the attackers posting the mia
culpa saying hey we we didn't mean to
attack the pipeline really sorry
this one kind of got out of hand which
is funny and who knows
anyway ashley i know you have a question
do you want to chime in with that sure
just
a question like there are just a
proliferation of cyber security
companies and i just wanted to ask like
i'm a newbie in in the space and i just
i'm just curious like what
differentiates like some of the
companies from others like
what are like the biggest challenges
these companies have i think it's that
the
he answered it which is awesome and that
is the differentiation is the big
challenge because there are so many and
you go to rsa and and every year it gets
twice as big as the prior year
and the marketing company copy from half
the companies is all identical and so
you're like how do you actually make how
do you make inroads with customers and
convince them that you're something
special
so that's i think that's the hardest
thing
the that differentiation is is really
the the biggest challenge marketing and
go to market become really difficult
there's this maslov's hierarchy of what
what do people want to spend money on so
first they want to spend money on things
that make them more money so increase
revenue second it's things that reduce
costs so make them more profit
and then third is avoid risk and most
cybersecurity products are down here at
the bottom luckily for the sector
there's a lot of fear here and execs
have lost their job because of
compromises and so there's 100 billion
dollars a year spent down here so
nothing to see that but it can be hard
to shake lose the buying cycle at the
bottom sometimes
some of the best cyber security
companies in the last 20 years are ones
that actually combine
number two and number three so they end
up delivering great cyber security but
they're selling to people that just want
to use them to make their lives better
increase efficiency these are things
like titanium or going even farther back
big fix which was a patch management
product
so software needs to be updated with
patches often because vulnerabilities
are discovered and if you don't patch it
then you're compromised in the future
bigfix was just hey it leads we're going
to make your life better by automating
what used to be a really painfully
manual thing to do
and
that improved security to no end but it
wasn't improved security wasn't why
people were buying it it was because it
it made them
much happier and how they did their
daily job and made them more efficient
did that answer your question i was
riffing on a few random threads there
yeah i might ask a follow-up on that so
i was also curious how important it is
that this cyber security software or
systems are compatible to the legacy
systems that companies use if they're
selling these products to enterprises
and is it fine that like
companies are more open to use like a
standalone cybersecurity product that's
new in the market or
like the threshold or the entry bar is
high
you
almost all cyber security companies have
to create a whole bunch of integrations
with other cyber security vendors so
there's there are sims which are
security event management
products which are designed to be a
landing point for all sorts of data and
alerts from other systems so you have to
first have to integrate with them often
you have to integrate with firewalls
and it becomes a big capital sync for
any atscale startup the one exception
and this is a standout success in the
last five years is zscaler
which said
we're going to make life for smbs
especially easier by just making cyber
security easy to easy to acquire and
deploy
you're not going to have to do anything
on-prem it's all going to be hosted and
you just point all your traffic to
z-scaler and we'll take care of the rest
it made no claim to having the best
firewall the best ids for the best
endpoint but it was the easiest to use
and it
has been an incredible tear and it's
just an incredible success story so you
can also you can compete via better
technology and better efficacy or you
can just make it all easier to use and
win
often twice as much in this way versus
this way yep
so tj we have about 15 minutes left so i
do want to touch upon enterprise ign
what do you look for when investing in
enterprise startups and how do you
decide on where to put your money in and
i think even just the example that you
gave with zscaler is hints a little bit
upon that in terms of there's different
ways that startups can succeed and
grow in revenue and would love for you
to rift on that a little bit more
yeah we're all
we all kind of get locked in based on
experiences i've seen success in the
past from teams that take a clean sheet
approach
to
again standing bucket suspend and pure
storage was a good example because it
said hey we can take consumer flash and
apply for the enterprise use cases in
ways that existing storage vendors
really can't do because they've got this
entire legacy stack of software that's
written for spinning disk and so a clean
sheet approach meant a better product
more usability and a funny story about
pure was that it it had a design
criteria for its first product that said
our installation manual needs to be
printed on a business card
and they migrated off it a bit and made
it both sides of the business card
but it was that ease of use that hadn't
really never been seen in enterprise
storage before that so impressive and
made people
happy to deploy their systems
and we see in the same approach you can
imagine how much easier it is to deliver
that kind of easy use in cloud systems
but we've invested against other
primarily on-prem systems recently it's
a little counter-trend but we're seeing
great success since the majority of
spend and i t is still not in cloud
these are systems like database systems
more storage that's taking advantage of
new memory types and new compression
approaches and then again we're looking
at the we're looking at how you extend
enterprise id to cloud effectively then
we get back into the cyber security on
when we think about that tj i was
wondering if you have any opinions on
shifts that we've seen and how
organizations buy enterprise technology
today and if i'm a founder thinking
about starting an enterprise it company
how should i really capitalize on those
shifts
if there are any yeah i know it's
dramatic and every rfp is either the
company is determined to shift the
workload to the cloud
or they're considering it so you need to
be ready to compete on that or to offer
just to host a solution the second thing
that we've been watching and we've
really seen the momentum flip in the
last few years probably isn't news to
anybody
almost every organization is ready to
buy on a subscription model and
sometimes you'll get the sense that yeah
really they'd prefer perpetual with an o
m stream
and that's just doesn't seem to be the
case anymore everybody's ready for
subscription if you just push them in
that in that direction and all investors
care about is seeing recurring revenue
so that becomes pretty critical for
future fundraising and for growing the
business long term so when you invested
in cloudera i think you tell what made
you decide to do that investment
you know finally i had a bunch of really
knocked out arguments with people about
whether
the government agencies that we work
with
had any big data and that was in
retrospect ironic because these are big
data-driven organizations everybody's
got a lot of data these days right cloud
era was interesting because it was
different from
existing approaches so getting back a
little bit to that clean sheet
approach to a standing challenge we had
just gone through
several years of mostly parallel relate
relational databases so these are like
astra data terra cream plum par excel
which is now redshifted at amazon and
all of them were good products but very
much the same thing which was a
smart approach to sharding postgres in
ways that took away some of the pain of
sharding
cloudera and the nosql trend around
hadoop and the rest of no sequel
territory or a sector was all about how
do you change how data is stored and how
do you do late binding a schema to a
giant data lake
and so the fact that it was so different
made us believe that it had a good
amount of runway and could be useful and
not for everything not for highly
performant databases but for the kind of
giant data lakes the big organizations
we're going to have in the future
and how do you assign evaluation to an
enterprise i.t company versus
other companies
since a lot of investors will use a
fairly specific mathematical formula for
that
yeah and we try to get early enough
where it
isn't it isn't as tied to comps it's
more an understanding of just how big
the market is and whether the company
has the unique approach to to build
something very special
all of these comps are being rewritten
right now and snowflakes the high water
mark uh but there'll be another one in
the future that will
will be just a you know
profound shift in in how investors want
to value companies to me it makes it
nicer to get
pre-revenue when we get going with a
company or early revenue
because
the multiple expansion in the last year
especially has gone from something like
let's value a company based on
10 times forward recurring earnings
to
or revenue to 40 or 50. and so the
market comp now is in a lot of cases
that 40 to 50 range or far higher
depending on whether you've got
particular lunacy in the bid from other
investors so i can't pretend there's a
ton of logic there ernestine but i just
say that the public market valuations
ultimately drive it and for people that
invested in snowflake at 9 or 10 billion
that's paid off really well and then
everybody else has that in mind as
they're trying to get into the next
snowflake
yeah definitely different than a
robotics investment for instance yeah
what are other technology trends do you
um see as what would you put your
dollars into beyond
robotic cyber security and enterprise id
it's it's smart applications of ai and
ml we talked a little bit it was what
can we do with yeah i
actually had asked this
about applications of reinforcement
learning deep learning
there are good good um places to take it
today and it just makes for great
software great applications and so
anytime you can deliver value to
companies through this big step forward
in application functionality i think
it's a good bet
any tech trends that you think are just
over hyped and should not be worth
investing in commercial space is a
dangerous area
it goes back to who doesn't want to talk
to their friends about how they invested
in a rocket company yeah spacex rocket
lab notwithstanding there are too many
rocket companies out there and
very few exits to date in any form of
commercial space
so i i think they're going to be a lot
of a lot of sunk dollars there
until all the spat companies um just buy
them because they have a two-year
timeline to spend their money or return
i think you're right yeah that's the
amazing thing about spaxx is that
ticking clock
and then and then our investment theses
just get flipped on its head again and
we think we should invest in space
companies now but i do agree that i
think that the applications for space
are pretty far off especially if you
think about it from a traditional
revenue and growth standpoint i would
love to finally touch upon some of your
really interesting
work more on the non-profit side and
specifically the work that you've done
with institute for security and
technology and would love for you to
just describe at a high level what is
the work that you do with them and why
is this important i think it's very rare
to see a lot of private for-profit
investors also focused on policy and
technology and i've always found that to
be a pretty unique angle that you've
taken
thanks yeah i'm a huge believer and what
is institute for security technology is
all about it's a startup itself and is
if i think about the analog to money
making a for-profit startup it's
probably in the series b series c range
has done a ton it's created a great
first grade i created early product it's
probably a great team it's seen a lot of
of great traction recently and has
driven a lot of value most recently it
had a
90 page report that came out where it
was managing a task force around
ransomware and it made a lot of pretty
interesting policy recommendations it's
worth checking out if anybody's
interested in that topic this is a team
that wants to recast what it means to be
a think tank and to drive to action and
drive to impact in a very authentically
west coast way so being very tech
centric intersecting with big tech
companies in addition to
information consumers in the government
and the core value prop the core need
that this team's identified
is that the pace of technological change
is only accelerating we've known that
for a long time as technologies emerge
and the world changes there are both
opportunities but also threats from
those new technologies that people need
to think of they need to think of beyond
the open market context so policy
becomes important understanding becomes
important so that we don't do things to
stifle technologies but also don't
expose
the world to risks from new technologies
i especially like that that isd thinks
in a global context it's not
institute for the u.s technology
uh security and security technology it's
really what does the world need to do to
think about
what does it mean for
us to apply
modern technology to
nuclear command control or cyber
security one interesting thing that came
out of the cyber security task force
report was
should it be illegal kind of in like a
foreign corrupt
practices act way for a victim of
ransomware to pay any ransom
and that's pretty provocative i think a
lot of people have probably talked about
that but why it all holds water until
you're the one that's been affected so
anyway i think that they're doing great
work i'm on the board and so i take
little claim for any of the great work
but i help them where i can and they
operate as a pretty effective non-profit
and one that if if you have any standing
anybody has any standing interest in it
i'm sure they'd love to have more people
in the ecosystem that want to
participate
thanks for sharing that final question
i'm going to pull this question from
something that spencer was curious about
in terms of as you progressed in your
career what prompted different shifts in
terms of for instance leaving bcg to go
to inquitel leaving utah to get an x47
and
any general career advice on that front
nobody wants to know why i left enron
maybe that as well
i was lucky enough to get into grad
school and i left enron to come to
california and then everything hit the
fan and i learned all the hard lessons
from that i left bcg it was a fantastic
experience learned a ton never wanted to
do it again
and i wasn't all that good at it and
what i really wanted to do is work with
early stage tech startups and i was
pretty sure it was being an operational
role inc utah was an opportunity that i
really latched onto because i wanted to
give back to the intelligence community
and i figured i'd be there for two years
maybe three years and then going to one
of these operational roles and i was not
at all attracted to the investment job
description i had met some investors
business school classes and wasn't very
impressed frankly and so not really
knowing what the job description is all
about not understanding things i had
this negative opinion ankita was a
fantastic 10 years and it allowed me to
feel like i made a contribution learn a
lot about startups and just more than
anything have the pleasure of working
with some great teams that were building
really impactful products
and i grew to like the investment role
and that was after i really understood
what it was all about and then after 10
years i felt like it was time to
shift gears and invest for
financial return and had an opportunity
to try to grow a new firm along with a
couple of partners
and significant standing resources which
is next 47 so that was a great
opportunity